>> One thing I like about Android is that
it enables you to build one application that
can adjust itself dynamically to different
devices. So, and this is possible because
the UI is created in XML and the resources
of the UI layouts are packaged in a very smart
way. So when you inflate the UIs from XML,
the runtime itself, the platform itself choose
the best layout for different screens. So,
in that way, you can create only one application
package that will actually adjust itself for
different screen sizes, different color depths,
or just different devices. One thing I would
like to see on Android is support for Java
Native Interface in order to run some processor
specific tasks in the platform native language.
So, in our case, for Shazam, we create the
fingerprints. But for right now, we--for our
library to create fingerprints is done--is
we use it on the service side. Having the
JNI will enable us to make the fingerprints
of the phone and send the latest data to the
servers.